on May 19th 2015 CD Projekt RED released
what many considered to be one of the
best role-playing games of all time The
Witcher 3 Wild Hunt 5 years later as we
usher in a new console generation let's
explore what made this game a remarkable
achievement and a powerhouse in the
video game industry
[Music]
now before we look at the game itself
it's important to set the stage the Xbox
one and ps4 had been on the market for
roughly a year and a half and while
there were some great games for our
shiny new consoles nothing felt truly
next-gen part of this was due to the
fact that most games were cross-gen
meaning they launched on ps3 and xbox
360 as well as ps4 and Xbox one even the
best games of 2014 like Dragon Age
Inquisition and titanfall were designed
with the old tech in mind meanwhile the
games made specifically for Xbox one and
ps4
felt more like ambitious tech demos than
full fledged games or they were just
really buggy cross-gen games are pretty
common at the start of a new generation
but there was a dreaded new trend that
was starting to become commonplace in
Triple A games microtransactions
microtransactions were nothing new when
it came to mobile games but they were
rapidly popping up in triple-a
experiences Microsoft even made it
crystal clear that every one of its
first party games for the foreseeable
future would have in-game purchases
fortunately if dears tactics is any
indication they may have eased off that
policy now you're probably wondering why
I'm talking about microtransactions in a
video about The Witcher 3 but bear with
me while this was all happening a modest
studio in Poland was hard at work on the
final installment of their mature
fantasy series unlike many of the games
released in 2013 and 2014 The Witcher 3
Wild Hunt was built from the ground up
to fully utilize the new consoles CD
Projekt RED wanted to create a world as
detailed as it was big with a lengthy
branching narrative that would keep
players invested for dozens if not
hundreds of hours if that wasn't enough
they made it abundantly clear that there
would be no microtransactions and all
small DLC packs would be entirely free I
really think the word DLC it's evaluated
there are some new C's which are like
good old expansions and then I'll
probably prefer to call them expansion
yeah if it's a DLC if it's
hairstyle weapon armoire horse armor
maybe and this should be the city for
free me although not every Triple A game
at the time had microtransactions it was
refreshing to see a developer like CD
Projekt RED takes such a firm stance
against in-game purchases however none
of that would matter if The Witcher 3
Wild Hunt didn't meet fan expectations
[Music]
on May 19 2015 after a couple delays The
Witcher 3 launched on PlayStation 4 Xbox
one and PC 2 overwhelmingly positive
reviews GameSpot's Kevin Bay Nord
awarded it a 10 saying excellence of
bounds at every turn in this open-world
role-playing game excellent exploration
excellent creature design excellent
combat mechanics and excellent player
progression
despite the Witcher threes unprecedented
scale there was still so much care put
into the finer details from the side
quest to the optional monster hunts
everything felt weighty and worthwhile
thanks to the jaw-dropping presentation
and sharp writing rarely if ever did
Strang off the beaten path feel like a
waste of time there is always something
new to learn and explore what still
impresses me to this day is how complex
and well-thought-out the narrative is
there weren't just good and bad
decisions with obvious consequences
instead CD Projekt RED went a subtler
route seemingly small decisions could
have big repercussions both good and bad
no matter what you did you'd still
second-guess yourself the glue that kept
everything together though were the
game's vivid and fantastic characters
even beyond the core cast there were so
many excellent side characters like the
bloody baron Johnny Lambert Keira Metz
and so on
financially The Witcher 3 was also a
huge success selling over 6 million
copies in the first six weeks and over
20 million as of 2019 the success didn't
go unnoticed either many developers have
taken inspiration from The Witcher 3
most notably Ubisoft Assassin's Creed
series Assassin's Creed origins marked a
fresh start for the series and with that
we saw many nods to CD Projekt Reds
open-world RPG such as the quest
progression and loot system the only
thing missing was a branching narrative
which appeared in the next
Assassin's Creed Odyssey the success of
The Witcher 3 also had massive
repercussions for CD Projekt RED the
team greatly expanded both in head count
and office space opening a new studio in
Poland a few years later GOG CD Projekt
Reds PC games storefront took a
respectable market share from Steam
putting their DRM policy front and
center and of course I think it's safe
to say that the witcher 3 success has
influenced cyberpunk 2077 s development
in some way or another it's impossible
to say exactly what cyberpunk 2077 would
look like had the witcher 3 flopped but
i'd imagine the final product would be
very different
and of course i'd be willing to bet that
if the witcher 3 wasn't as successful as
it was the netflix witcher show probably
wouldn't exist while I do have some
qualms with the show there's no denying
the impact it had never in my wildest
dreams that I think my parents would be
chatting about Geralt of Rivia and
Cyrilla Fiona Ellen Rhiannon around the
dinner table but here we are and I
couldn't be happier about it as always
thank you so much for watching and let
us know what your favorite moments are
in The Witcher 3 down below we'll see
you next time
[Applause]
you